the pope Leahy house is a striking
example of Frank Lloyd Wright's work a
Cypress and brick Masterpiece so
connected to Nature it includes a
kitchen window made for reaching out and
picking herbs one of the highlights of
this home is its unusual Windows these
features are a striking sign of the way
Frank Lloyd Wright rethought the
relationship between homes and natural
light
if you walk through the galley from the
entry to the bedroom you'll find light
hun like pictures on the wall
the most distinctive windows in this
house the perforated windows are called
clear story windows at the top an old
technique that Wright embraced they
bring natural light into the room from
ceiling height preserving privacy and
lighting the room more broadly
the subtle effect Echoes that of the
recessed lighting that he favored
these perforations were designs right
made as an evolution of his stained
glass windows like these ones in a 1921
house that Wright built
[Music]
each type of house like the pope Leahy
house received their own unique design
later he simplified even more with glass
set into concrete blocks
I could not believe that I found this
model like I was there earlier this week
and then when I programmed in the exact
date and time that I shot a specific
clip
at the house your model matched the
light perfectly
John latrop's painstakingly designed 3D
model of the Pope Leahy house lets
anyone play around with light then you
can render a more realistic version that
is super accurate if I shot the clip at
4 42
429 the light was a little off but if I
put in 442 it was exactly correct I mean
did you know that that would happen no I
had no idea that it was that accurate
what I usually do is I try to find
at least the floor plan and and the four
elevations and then I'll dig around for
photos too to get the details in
so for the design of those perforated
windows were you able to just look at
pictures and then in SketchUp kind of
carve out the proper pattern yes I found
a um a very good drawing of it online
that was to scale and that I used as my
basis for it these clear story windows
were combined with other perforated
Windows of the same design like these in
the child's bedroom and large wall sized
windows that let in tons of light
throughout the day but all this would
have been just a design touch if it
weren't at the center of a broader
attempt to make light part of the house
[Music]
I didn't think I was going to like the
house as much as I did I thought well it
doesn't look like it's a very big house
which isn't but it also didn't look like
it had a very good layout from what I
could tell from just looking at floor
plans and a few bad photographs that I
that were out there at the time but
being in the house
was such a different experience you know
that that entryway and then the walk
down into the living room and Tiny but
really functional kitchen
um the office off to the side
and a fireplace and Wright always builds
a fireplace to be this special thing
this place where people can gather
around and in that house it really felt
that way this house is what Wright
called a usonian his model for a new
American house
as an architect Wright was famous for
legendary large projects from the Roby
house to Tokyo's Imperial Hotel to the
Johnson wax headquarters after earlier
experiments in affordable housing by the
1930s he was seriously seeking to bring
his principles to more people as he
later wrote in the natural house he
believed in a building as dignified as a
tree in the midst of nature the Herbert
Jacobs house in Madison Wisconsin is
considered Wright's first usonian and a
Time magazine article about Wright and
that Jacob's house inspired a DC area
journalist to beg right to build him a
usonian too
the pope Leahy house features many right
trademarks that help the distinctive
Windows light the house in God's way the
natural way as nearly as possible in the
daytime and at night as nearly like the
day one is clearing obstructions a
relatively open floor plan lets light
travel see how the living room and
dining room area connect radiant floor
heating means no radiators took up space
or obstructed light write hated addicts
for a similar reason so he recommended
people get rid of the attic and if they
didn't they use a clear story or Lantern
instead of garage this house features an
open-air carport as well shade via
trellises offered occupants flexibility
and perhaps most importantly the
unadorned walls no paint no plaster no
curtains unless by special requests put
the pattern of light at the center of
the adornment for the house
this was a stark break from a lot of
design at the time where relatively
small windows were covered walls were
plastered and Floors were carpeted house
beautiful magazine put together
demonstration homes in The Plaza Hotel
they represented the prevailing
aesthetic closed floor plan carpet lots
of curtains visible light features
basically anything that blocked light
[Music]
the usonian challenged Trends it didn't
become ubiquitous but the design meant
light was as important a material as
brick and wood
levittowns are some of the most famous
Suburban Mass developments in the United
States they were in some ways the
antithesis of Wright's dream of organic
interaction between a house and nature
but developers William and Alfred
Levitt's open floor plan design was
inspired by Wright's approach
the levittowner in particular copied
natural light Design Elements like
carports window walls and even high
windows but Wright's massive influence
doesn't capture the scope of his
philosophy he hoped that Architects
would prioritize the proper orientation
of the house to make windows work well
with the light how did you figure out
the orientation the floor plan I had had
the north Airlines you know that's
always helpful
[Music]
the pope Leahy house was actually moved
to its current location in Alexandria
Virginia it was designed to face South
before being built facing Northwest and
then reoriented slightly during moves at
Woodlawn
the light creates a different house not
only at different times of year but in
different locations
Frank Lloyd Wright didn't just consider
the placement of the windows
but also the position
of the Stars
[Music]
foreign